medical expert dr bill comrade de blasio
is now demanding in new york city that
the people of new york city
follow his strict new covert 19
guidelines
or they risk losing their freedom that
their freedom will be taken
away pay close attention to what he says
here
the delta variant has changed the game
unless we want to run the risk of going
back to restrictions
and having our freedom taken away and
people losing their jobs again
it's really clear what we have to do so
here's a clear message
we're saying you want to go and enjoy
great restaurants
amen you want to go to movie theaters go
to the gym that's great we want all that
you got to get backstage you want to
work in those places you got to get
vaccinated for the good and the health
of everyone around you as well
it's not that tough to do he says you're
going to risk
losing your freedom well that's kind of
strange
because his measure takes away
everybody's freedom
and by the way uh comrade de blasio
our rights actually come from god the
creator you know of
everything uh not from you comrade bill
de blasio
but apparently bill thinks he knows best
he's a new york politician and a failure
at that after all
so forget about consulting with your
doctor or medical privacy or patient
doctor confidentiality
if you don't follow comrade de blasio's
rules in new york
city and get vaccinated and present your
papers
to anyone who requests it you will no
longer be allowed to enter
a restaurant a gym see a movie broadway
show
go to a concert nothing you will be shut
out
show us your papers get the vaccine
mandated
or you're out what about people that
have rare conditions
who can't get the vaccine because their
doctors tell them that it would harm
them
what about those that had covered if
we're following the science the
cleveland clinic
says very prestigious medical
institution
that if you had covert 19 you don't need
any of the vaccines
what happened to follow the science that
mantra
but now as de blasio just mentioned we
don't follow his orders
all of your precious freedom not only
could be stripped away but he's
stripping it away anyway at the drop of
a hat
a perfect example of why it's never a
good idea
to elect a devout well socialist marxist
communist
authoritarian figure like bill de blasio
and it's not just him at biden's request
now democrats across the country
they're eagerly implementing new masked
mandates what happened if you get
vaccinated life goes back to normal
they're now mandating vaccine
requirements and vaccine
passports social distancing even for
kids in school
restrictions on all businesses and
breaking tonight as we reported at the
top
well now our pentagon will soon announce
a coven 19
vaccine mandate for every single member
of our military whether they want it or
not
and los angeles by the way they might
soon mandate vaccine passports just like
new york
and get this yesterday we had this
genius that runs the nih their director
actually encouraging parents at home
that have children
that you must put your masks on at home
inside your house
okay we are now dealing with lunatics
these are the same people that said if
you got the vaccine
life goes back to normal are you going
to believe them now
because they lied to us because that
never happened
and clearly they don't believe in
something called freedom
but if you question the so-called
experts you oppose the government
mandates
you're guilty of killing people
according to new jersey governor
phil murphy another idiot with one of
those executive orders
putting covet positive people in nursing
homes take a look
these folks back there have lost their
mind you've lost your minds
you are the ultimate knuckleheads and
because of what you are saying and
standing for
people are losing their life people are
losing their life
and you have to know that look in the
mirror
look in the mirror did you governor or
did you not sign an executive order
forcing nursing homes to take covert
positive patience
we're going to get lectures from you
without a doubt the dramatic lectures
from the left are
once again ramping up at the same time
they're not going to say a word about
the biggest super spreader event
that has been ongoing since january 20th
right at our own southern border the
biden
super spreader the state of disaster
has now been declared in mcallen texas
why because
seven thousand coveted positive illegal
immigrants
were released into that one city alone
including 1500 just this past week
this is now more than a million illegal
immigrants were apprehended at the
border
we're now at a 25-year high when we were
at a 25-year low
with donald trump's border policy now we
have no idea how many
more were not intercepted by law
enforcement a
record number of illegal immigrants from
all over the world
many with covert none of them being
tested
nobody's being vaccinated no mandates
for them
and they're now being dispersed in buses
and planes
to every state in the in the country and
they're all being paid for
by you courtesy of joe biden but if you
turn
on fake news cnn or msdnc or abc nbc cbs
or read the new york times and
washington post
you're not going to hear anything about
this massive super spreader event they
didn't tell you about joe's cages for
kids
in the middle of a pandemic that were
overcrowded and they're on top of each
other
yeah in the middle of a pandemic with a
high rate of covet positivity
but according to the mob the media big
tech the biden administration
well governor ron de santos let's blame
him
the guy whose schools have been open now
for a full
year they go we're going to blame him
all because why he's not going to force
three-year-olds to wear masks
and today governor desantis guess what
he had this powerful response
for joe biden and circle back jenn
sackey take a look
joe biden is taken to himself to try to
single
out florida over covid this is a guy who
ran for president saying he was going to
quote
shut down the virus and what has he done
he's imported more virus from around the
world by having a wide open southern
border
biden he rejects science
because he denies the fact that people
that recover from covid
have long lasting immunity and that's
been proven
time and time again and the data is very
clear so you're trying to restrict
people
impose mandates if you're trying to ruin
their jobs and their livelihoods and
their small business
if you are trying to lock people down
i am standing in your way and i'm
standing for the people of florida so
why don't you do your job
why don't you get this border secure and
until you do that
i don't want to hear a blip about covid
from you
thank you well said and by the way it
was governor desantis he mobilized early
every single every single sector of his
government
to focus on the most vulnerable the
elderly population
in florida to protect them unlike new
york new jersey pennsylvania
and michigan oh where they were putting
covert positive patients in nursing
homes
and killing the most vulnerable
population the biden administration is
actually concerned with the spread of
covert
close the border joe close the border
that's the biggest super spreader you're
responsible
for the biggest super spreader event in
the entire history
of the covid uh pandemic in this country
that would prevent thousands of
unvaccinated illegal immigrants that
you're processing every day
by not literally enforcing the laws of
the land
from pouring across our borders
illegally
that would stop those infected with
culver 19 from getting into the country
likely infecting american citizens that
you keep giving conflicting messages to
but clearly trashing governor desantis
is more important to joe biden hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else